- Hello everyone, welcome to
Khan Academy's Daily Homeroom.
For those of y'all who aren't
familiar with what this is,
ever since we had the mass school closures
because of the COVID-19
all of us at Khan Academy
as a not-for-profit
with a mission of providing
a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere
realized that it's our duty
to do whatever we can to support students,
parents, and teachers through this crisis.
So, obviously over many years
we've been building resources
in math, and English and language arts,
and early learning, Khan Academy Kids,
you can see Kodi Bear right behind me,
going all the way through
high school level sciences and SAT prep,
but we realized once the schools
were going to get closed
that people needed even more.
So we've been doing webinars
for parents and teachers
to understand how to structure things.
We've been releasing
schedules on what students,
how they could structure their days
based on different age groups,
and we've been doing this live stream,
this Daily Homeroom so
we can feel connected
in this time of social distancing.
We do have a cool announcement.
Just yesterday we released
what we're calling
Learning Plans on Khan Academy
and I think you're gonna
see some of the links.
There you go, the link is right there.
It's magical.
There, I can get my,
there you go.
(chuckling)
Felipe is doing a better job,
is getting fancier every day.
But if you go there
what you're going to see
is we got a lot of feedback from,
especially students and parents saying,
"All right the schedules were useful.
"I can understand that I can do, maybe,
"40 minutes of math then take a break,
"then do 40 minutes of
reading, et cetera, et cetera,
"but over the course
of the next two months
"or even five months
as we go through summer
"what are reasonable goals
for me or for my child?
"How do I make sure either myself
"or my child is keeping up
"so that they're ready
for next school year?"
So this is a week by week learning plan
that sets goals for you,
if you're the student,
or your child if you're
the parent, to be on track.
And this first Learning Plan we've done
is focused on math.
Khan Academy has much more than just math,
but math is one of
those core subject areas
where it's really valuable to make sure
that you don't fall behind.
Obviously, even before this COVID crisis
we have talked a lot about
the importance of mastery learning,
about not being pushed ahead
while you still have gaps
that accumulate over time,
these Swiss cheese gaps,
and Khan Academy can help fill you in.
And then you could
imagine with five months
of not being in school now
it's that much more important
to fill in those gaps
and to keep learning.
And just to underline that
our partners at the NWEA,
they're a non-profit assessment body,
they just released a report yesterday
'cause they have historical data
on what's known as the
summer learning loss,
or the summer slide.
Normally you have three months
of loss over the summer,
not just not learning,
but oftentimes forgetting,
now it might be five months.
And in that world it could be as much
as a year of learning loss.
So please take a look
at those learning plans
and give us feedback.
The other thing I'd like to,
just out of a shout out, a thank you,
Khan Academy, we are not-for-profit,
we are funded by philanthropic donations,
you own as much of Khan Academy as I,
or anyone else, it has no ownership,
it's a public charity,
and we need your support.
Even before the crisis we
were running at a deficit
and now our server costs, et cetera,
are going up many fold,
and we're trying to put out more support.
So if you're in a position to do so
please think about donating.
I do wanna give a special thanks
to several corporations
who've stepped up recently
including Bank of America,
AT&T, Google.org, and Novartis.
That's been a major
help, but we need more.
We're still running at a
deficit to do all of this.
So with that, today's live stream
I thought that we could
have a little bit of fun.
We have fun all the time,
but we're gonna keep it
a little bit freeform.
If you're watching this over YouTube,
or you're watching it over Facebook,
put any question you might
possibly be curious about there.
We have team members
that are looking at 'em,
and everything is fair game.
Dan is here and he's gonna help me out,
identifying what folks are saying.
But, you know, we're more than happy
to answer questions about some
of what I just talked about.
How do you structure your day?
Questions about learning and education.
We're happy to at least
think about questions about
some of the healthcare
stuff that's going on
as much as we are qualified to do so.
Economic things, or just other things
that are going on in your life.
We're gonna, we're gonna...
Inside our organization
we have these things
called "Ask Me Anything".
We're gonna make this an
Ask Me Anything version
of our life stream, so
ask us literally anything.
And let's see.
I'm gonna see some of our team members
are starting to put out.
So Susanna from YouTube,
Susanna Garcia Dominguez,
and Susanna you've been
asking good questions
on this live stream (chuckles)
I remember your name off
of YouTube, is asking
"Will you be releasing a
learning plan for first grade?"
So that is an excellent question.
So your question by itself
is a little bit of a push for us to do it.
First grade is an
interesting overlap subject
or grade level for us
because Khan Academy Kids
goes up through first grade.
And then the Khan Academy
that is not Khan Academy Kids,
we have to come up with
a better name for that
'cause that's still for kids and adults,
it starts at that kindergarten
first grade level.
So I think what your question
is a really good push.
Hopefully over the next
couple of days or weeks
we can work with the
Khan Academy Kids team
to maybe put something together
or put something together that's a hybrid
of Khan Academy Kids and the math,
'cause these first learning
plans are math focused
on non-Khan Academy Kids
Khan Academy. (chuckling)
All right.
From Facebook Jacqui Riquelme says,
"Could you please share
what software you use
"to record video lessons?
"I would love to use the writing tool
"to explain in better details
with video for my students.
"Thank you so much."
So Jacqui it sounds like
you might be a teacher,
and I know a lot of teachers
even before this crisis
were interested in making,
I guess you could say,
Khan Academy style videos.
And especially with school closures
it's even more important.
So, what I use, and it's
good that it's right here.
So, let me see if I can
show this to you,
I'm picking it up.
(mic thudding)
There's a little bit, ugh,
I'm bumping into all sorts of stuff.
This is a Wacom tablet I use.
I've upgraded over the years.
I use to have a, kind
of a smaller $80 one.
I think this one costs about $200.
And it will come with a
pen that looks like this.
And so that's what I use
to write when I'm doing it.
This microphone that you see here,
this is the microphone that I use.
And, once again, all of
this is kind of upgrade.
You don't needs these types of
things to do a decent video.
If you just have even, you know,
your regular headphone microphone
that's probably sufficient.
In the first several years of Khan Academy
I had a $80 tablet and
I just used a standard,
you know, $20 headset that you could find.
And I use an art program.
In the early days I was using
Microsoft Paint (chuckling)
now I use SketchBook, SketchBook Pro.,
which is just a nice drawing application.
And the way that I capture the drawing
and my voice is I use
Camtasia to screen capture.
And Camtasia isn't the only tool,
there's other tools that can allow you
to do some screen capture.
And I just,
what I do is I capture a portion.
I do a 1280x720 pixel
rectangle of my art tool,
and that's why you don't see
all the widgets and the tools
'cause they're outside
of the recording window.
So that's what I do, I just click record.
I try to do things fairly informally.
I think it's really valuable
when you're making videos
that it's not overly scripted
because I think the listener can detect
if you are going through
it with them or not,
so I try to keep it
reasonably extemporaneous
and low-key, but whatever works for you.
But, I encourage you to
definitely keep going with that.
All right.
So from Facebook Rick Cornett asks,
"How can I set up a science curriculum
"for my sixth and seventh grader?
"Math is set up by grade
level, but science is not."
That's a great question, Rick.
So Khan Academy, we don't yet.
It is our aspirations.
We don't yet have an
explicit science curriculum
for middle school students.
With that said, and I've said this
a couple of times on the live stream,
I think a sixth grader, or
a seventh grader is ready
to start engaging on parts
of the high school sciences.
So for example, high school biology,
which is on Khan Academy.
I am confident that your children,
especially if you're
there to support them,
can start learning the basics of biology.
And frankly, it's very relevant right now
to learn about DNA,
RNA, viruses, bacteria,
evolution, natural selection.
Obviously, with the viruses,
evolution and natural
selection is happening
before our eyes in real time.
So I would definitely look
at the high school biology
as a great thing for potentially sixth
or seventh graders.
They definitely have the
math background for it.
And then even the early units in chemistry
where you're learning about
the periodic table of elements,
what elements are, the basics of bonding,
the basics of balancing
chemical equations.
There's nothing there
that's cognitively beyond
a sixth or a seventh grader.
Especially, if they have some supports.
And physics is a little
bit more mathematical,
but there is even elements
of the physics where,
you know, maybe the one
dimensional motion or Newton's Laws
could be a really
interesting thing to tackle.
And if your students or your children
are able to do that now
they're going to have a serious leg up
when they get to true
high school level science.
So let's see.
We have another question here.
When I picked up my tablet
everything got messed up.
I'm, (chuckling) I'm trying, so.
Let's see.
So from Facebook
S. Wayne Smith says,
"Will you consider Khan Academy
"project-based learning activities?"
Great question.
So, this is something we've
always thought about doing,
and back in the day we
actually did release
a few pieces of content on it,
but I think the lens you're asking is
while schools are closed
or as we go into the summer
maybe in these learning plans
we can articulate things
to do above and beyond
the traditional academic
skill development,
or the stuff that could reinforce that.
So I think that's a great idea.
This is if our team,
or maybe we can partner
with some folks who can maybe supplement
the learning plans in the schedules
with that type of resource
I think it would be cool.
And it's just a matter of our
capability and our bandwidth.
But I definitely think
there's value in that.
So, from--
- Hey Sal--
- Oh, go, yeah.
- I, I.
So I have a question for you.
This is asked almost every
single live stream that we do.
It's a question on how did
you start Khan Academy?
And probably more
importantly people don't know
about this part, which is
who did you go to for help?
- Who did I go to help when
I started Khan Academy?
Or, like when I needed
help when I was a kid?
- Who did you go to for help
when you started Khan Academy?
- Oh, yeah so for those
of y'all who don't know,
and you can probably do a YouTube search
and find videos of me giving
a long winded explanation
of how Khan Academy started.
(chuckling)
I've been running off of
that story for a long time.
But there's a lot of folks who still don't
maybe know that story as much.
So back in 2004 I was, I
had just gotten married,
my original background was
in technology and in math,
but I had gone to business school
and I was now working
as an investment analyst
of all things.
And it just came out of
conversation after my wedding
my 12 year old cousin Nadia,
at the time, was visiting
and she was having trouble in math.
And so I said,
"Nadia I am confident that
you can master mathematics.
"How about when you go
back to New Orleans",
which is also where I was born,
"I'm willing to tutor you remotely."
I was living in Boston at the time.
And she agreed.
And she's probably like a lot
of you students listening.
She was 12 years old, she wanted to learn,
but she for many reasons
she had accumulated gaps
in her knowledge and had convinced herself
that maybe she wasn't
quote: "Good at math."
And many of you parents might relate,
her mom, Najudati, she was saying,
"Yeah I'm worried about Nadia.
"She's losing her confidence here."
And so those tutoring sessions,
I was doing it remotely.
I think a lot of you teachers
are finding yourselves
in that kind of a circumstance now
because of the closures.
And I was getting on the phone.
We didn't have things
like Zoom, and Hangouts,
and live streams back then.
But I was trying to find
ways that we could see
each other's writing,
and things like that.
But slowly but surely Nadia
was able to catch up with her class.
It was actually unit conversion
that she was having trouble with.
Then she actually got a
little bit ahead of her class.
Then I became what I call a "Tiger Cousin"
and I called up her school, and I said,
"You know I really think Nadia Rehman
"should retake that
placement test from last year
"that put her in that current math track."
And, you know, they famously
said, "Who are you?"
And I said, "I'm her cousin."
And they let her, (chuckles)
surprisingly take that test.
And that same Nadia who
thought she wasn't good at math
only a few months before
was then put into an advanced class.
And that same Nadia who
thought she couldn't understand
unit conversion when she was 12
by the time she was 13 she was
taking college level classes
at the University of New Orleans.
And I tell you that story
only partially to show off
on behalf of my cousin,
but more to tell many of you parents
and many of you students out there
that are thinking that you
are not good at something
it has nothing to do
with your innate ability.
The subject matter is not
fundamentally difficult.
It's likely because you have gaps.
And that's where Khan Academy
hopefully has your back.
And the silver lining of what
we're going through right now
over the next two months, and
probably the next five months
is this is a great opportunity
to leverage Khan Academy
to fill in those gaps.
We had Tim Vanderberg
on a couple of days ago,
amazing teacher out of
Hesperia in California
who makes all of his sixth
graders start Khan Academy
at the very basics starting
with the arithmetic course,
which starts literally at one plus one,
but if you know that material
you go through it really fast.
But that's the way that he ensures
that his kids don't have gaps.
And he has the student
population that starts the year
at 90% is well below grade level
and then he finishes the
year where they're able
to fill in their gaps and
most of them are accelerated
or are able to move ahead.
So, anyway going back to the story.
I was kinda hooked.
I started tutoring Nadia's
younger brothers as well.
Then word gets around in my family
that free tutoring is going on
and I found myself (chuckling)
tutoring 10, 15 cousins,
family friends around the country.
And Khan Academy, you
know, I had this background
in software engineering and I said,
"Well there aren't good
resources for my cousins
"to get practice and immediate feedback.
"What if I could make some of that
"and also provide a dashboard
for me as their coach
"or their teacher, or their tutor?
"So that I could understand
where their gaps were.
"So that I could dig a little bit deeper
"and assign appropriate
work for them", et cetera.
And that was the first Khan Academy.
It had nothing to do with videos,
which many people associate it with.
And it was in 2006 I was
showing off this software
to a friend at a dinner party.
As you can imagine I'm a
very fun dinner party guest
and I,
(laughing)
and he said, "Sal this is all cool,
"but how are you scaling
your actual lessons up?"
And said, I told him,
his name's Zuli Ramzan,
I have to give him full credit,
I said, "Zuli, it's hard
to scale my lessons.
"I feel like I'm repeating the same thing.
"I'm answering the same question
"oftentimes over and over."
And he said, "Well why don't you record
"some of your lessons as YouTube videos
"and upload them for your cousins?"
And I initially thought
it was a horrible idea.
I said, "No, YouTube is
for cats playing piano."
But I went home that weekend,
got over the idea that it wasn't my idea,
and I gave it a shot.
And then that took on a life of its own.
And, you know, I could go more in depth,
but by 2009 I just had, you
know this was three, four years
into this cousin project,
five years into it,
I had trouble focusing on my day job.
There were about 100,000 people
who were using it every month
and I said, "Surely, if I set
this up as a not-for-profit
"philanthropists will donate to this
"because the impact we could
have on the world is huge.
"If we translate it into
the language of the world,
"go across subjects and grades."
And, you know whenever you
start anything entrepreneurial
you have to start with
that delusional optimism
that surely the world will
conspire to make this happen.
And you usually realize quite quickly
that it was a little bit delusional.
But after about eight, nine
months of living off of savings
and openly it was probably one
of the most stressful times
in my life, I had given up a good career,
and my first child had just been born,
but after about 10 months all of a sudden
some philanthropists started
to come out of the woodwork,
and by 2010 we were able to
become a real organization.
So, anyway.
You got me on my soap box
telling the origin story of Khan Academy.
But I'm happy to answer any
other questions you have
on that front as well.
- Sal, there's actually
- So, oh,
- A follow-up to that.
- Oh yeah.
- So, on YouTube--
- Follow-up question, good.
- Yeah, on YouTube Sofia says,
"Great, where is Nadia now?"
and she also has a sister called Nadia.
- Oh (chuckling) very good.
So Nadia is now, if I'm
doing the math correctly,
she is 28 years old,
she lives in New York.
I was just Zoom conference calling
with her and her family
a couple of nights ago.
Obviously, everyone's
worried about the situation,
especially in New York.
But she is doing a masters,
and hopefully a PhD as well,
in clinical psychology.
She wants to become a
clinical psychologist,
therapist, type person.
So she is, we're very proud of her.
She is doing well.
Although I often joke with her
that there's a lot riding on her success.
(laughing)
That if that early intervention,
you know, if Nadia ends up,
anyway,
yeah, she's on track.
- And, Sal, Facebook,
Scott Yang on Facebook asks,
"Why is there a giant bear behind you?"
(chuckles) I don't think
everyone knows who Kodi is.
- There's a giant bear behind me?
Oh, yeah and you're right.
(Dan chuckling)
There's a giant bear behind me.
(laughing)
No.
So, my mom has actually kept saying,
she's like, "You know I
like these live streams,
"but your background is really horrible.
"Like, you have some random
junk behind you, Sal.
"You have to fix your background."
(chuckling)
And so, I actually went
looking this morning.
Right before this I was actually on CNN,
and my mom's like,
"If you're gonna be on CNN
"you gotta get a good background, Sal."
And I (chuckles) I just
started digging around
for what we have that could
make a decent background.
And this is what I found.
And for those of you who don't know,
this is Kodi Bear gazing over my shoulder.
He's kind of the primary
character in Khan Academy Kids.
So, this is a reminder that
that's available for you.
And,
and yeah,
and maybe having Kodi glare at you
will be a reminder to keep learning.
So, let's see.
There's a bunch of questions
I'm seeing here, Dan,
but feel free to jump in with more.
I see YouTube, Arev Jane says,
"What do I do when my brain gets stressed
"in reading or math?"
So, there's a lot to unpack
what that might be.
One thing that I've talked a lot about
in this live stream and other places
is just the value of meditation.
And meditation, it does not
have to be something fancy.
It literally can be, you know,
before you embark on something
give yourself two minutes
and just sit there
and close your eyes if it's useful,
soften your gaze, and just try to just,
try to observe your thoughts.
And what you find is the more you do it,
and the more consistently you do it
you start to realize that
you aren't your thoughts.
That you can observe your thoughts.
And the more that you
can observe your thoughts
the less overwhelming
that they can become.
And, you know, I think we've all felt
some of what you might be feeling Arev,
which is, you know,
you're reading something
and you're like,
"Wait, wait did I
understand that properly?"
and you keep rereading that same sentence.
I used to do that a lot.
I think in math, you know,
you're in a test or something,
or you're doing a problem and you're like,
you know there's a process
in your brain that's saying,
"Oh well you know how to do it.
"This is hard.
"What if you don't get this answer right?
"You might fail your math class."
and then that becomes a
little bit debilitating
'cause it doesn't allow
your brain to enter
into a kind of state of flow.
So that's one tip I have is,
you know, just meditation.
Actually, physical exercise
can be really good.
There is some evidence,
actually a lot of evidence,
that just getting that brain flowing,
running, et cetera, it
releases those endorphins,
and then when you sit down
to do something like reading,
or math, or anything that
you might find stressful
in your life you just realize that,
"Oh, you know, I'm just gonna
do it, see what happens."
So I think the more that
you just give yourself
permission to be, be in the moment,
don't try to think too much about
what's happened in the past
or what might happen in the future,
but just like, "Oh this is fun, I'm here.
"I'm this sentient being in the universe
"that is going to read
this entertaining book
"or that gets to puzzle through
"these interesting math questions."
I think you have that attitude
and it can really help.
You know, I've considered myself lucky
that throughout my life I've
always taken a fun attitude,
kind of an adventurous attitude
whenever I see a test or something
and I think it's really helped me.
It's like, "Oh this is fun,
it's a bunch of puzzles."
And I don't try to think too much
about what the outcomes might be
because that can be a little
bit stressful sometimes.
- Sal that was wonderful.
We have a related question
from Selena Chang on YouTube.
"Hi Sal, how can I find a passion project
"to pursue while in high school?"
- Great question, Selena.
So, meditation might help there.
You know, you might
(chuckling)
sit under a tree for a little while
and have an enlightenment experience.
Or, what I would do is really reflect,
like keep a lookout in the world for
where are there problems to be solved.
And this crisis we're in is highlighting
a lot of problems that have always existed
and they're introducing a set of new ones.
I've talked at this live stream,
I think there's many opportunities
for service projects right now.
It could be figuring out safe ways
to get groceries for, say, elderly people
in your community.
Ways to get food.
You know, we're going
through a financial situation
where a lot of people
have lost their jobs.
And I never thought it could be this way
in the United States, but there could be,
there's people probably not
too far from where you live
who are worried about
where their next meal
is going to come from.
So are there ways to coordinate, you know,
just dropping off the basics to folks,
milk, eggs, bread, things like that.
Are there ways to help
with some of the social
isolation people are feeling?
My mom, she's living by
herself in New Orleans,
and you know, she's the age population
that's high-risk for COVID,
and she's watching the news all day
and she's getting stressed,
so I've been telling, you
know, it's always important
for me to keep in touch with my mom,
but even more, like, for her mental health
it's super important for
me to keep connected,
and that she can see my kids,
and that she doesn't feel isolated.
But there's a lot of
people in her situation
who might be a little bit older,
who are alone at home,
who might not have someone
who is checking in on
them on a daily basis.
Maybe there's opportunities around that.
If you're more inclined on
the invention side of things,
you know, are there gloves you can create
that not only protect
you, but disinfect things
as you touch them, you know?
You can imagine a glove that
is made of some material,
or is doused in some material
that when you use it not
only does it protect you,
but it protects other people as well.
I mean, you can keep
imagining more and more things
that could help solve a lot of problems
for the world right now,
or it could've solved problems
that existed even before.
But I would just reflect on that.
And then when you feel some
energy around something
just run with it.
And as I've talked about
in other live streams
there's an opportunity here.
The silver lining is a lot of the things
that historically keep
young people super busy
with, you know, hours
of homework every night
and this practice and that practice,
a lot of that's gone now.
And so you have more time
to be able to dig deep into something.
You know, if it's coding there's
resources on Khan Academy.
And people talked about
project-based learning,
that is one area where Khan Academy has
what I would describe as
project-based learning
to be able to code and create things.
You can make apps to solve
interesting problems.
Ah, so yeah, the world's
your oyster right now.
It's a great opportunity
to do that type of thing.
But make sure it's something
that appeals to you.
You're not trying to
do it for other people,
you're not saying,
"Oh how will this look on
a college application?"
Do it because it's authentically something
you're interested in, and by the way,
if you do that it actually will look good
on a college application.
(chuckling)
'Cause it'll be truly you
and it'll be authentic.
So, there are questions.
Let's see, from Facebook
Sandra Edwards asks:
"So much has changed over the past month.
"What positive changes have you noticed
"coinciding with more
people being online?"
Well,
you know,
it's hard to talk about
too many positive things
because it's a tough,
tough period right now.
Some of the positive things I've seen,
and this transcends Khan Academy
is, you know, what I just talked about.
This crisis has made me realize
that I have to stay connected with more
of my friends and family.
Many of whom, I might have
not spoken to for a while.
So I'm making sure that I'm
calling up cousins and uncles,
and friends from high school.
So in a strange way the social distancing
is making us think beyond just the people
that we normally see
on a day to day basis.
So that might be a silver lining,
that we're connecting
with a lot more people.
I think this crisis reminds
us of what's really important.
All of us get caught up in the day to day.
If you're a student you're like,
"Oh I got that assignment due.
"I got that homework.
"Am I gonna, the SAT, college.
"What's my career choice?"
But if you think about it,
those are important things,
and obviously us adults
we're always thinking about,
"Oh, you know, that
project I'm working on."
Or that next goal, or that next event,
or whatever it might be.
And all of those things are important,
but they're not the most important thing.
The most important thing is your health,
your mental health, your connections,
your support networks.
And I think it's times like this
when you realize just how fragile we are,
how fragile in certain
ways society can be,
that it refocuses you on
the really important things.
The things that really
fulfill us as human beings
versus these hoops that
we keep jumping through
our whole lives and maybe
when we're older we realize,
"Why did I jump through so many hoops?
"Why didn't I spend more
time with my parents
"while they were alive?
"Why didn't I connect with those cousins
"when I had a chance?"
Et cetera, et cetera.
So I think that is bringing that.
You know, we're spending
more time with family.
That's positive.
On the education side of things,
you know, this is a very
suboptimal situation,
but the silver lining is
some of these techniques
that are having to happen where
students are having to build
a little bit more independence,
a little bit more agency,
and they're still supported
by parents and teachers,
that skill is actually
a super valuable skill.
It's more valuable than knowing
how to factor a polynomial,
is learning how to learn.
And so I'm hoping for the students
who are able to build that muscle,
hopefully many of y'all
are listening right now,
that's gonna pay dividends
if you can keep applying it
in the summer, and keep
applying it your whole life.
Because it's not like, you know,
the days of going to K through 12,
and then going to college,
and then just having skills
that you will use the rest of
your life until you retire.
Those days are over.
You're going to have to
be a life long learner.
And so it's a great time to, kind of,
take that agency on your own.
So, that could be a silver lining as well.
But, obviously if I were to list
a lot of the suboptimal
things right now (chuckling)
the list would get long.
But, good question to focus
on the silver linings.
So, let's see.
There's a question from
Facebook Saif Siddiqui asks:
"Can you please add subjects of commerce
"as per Indian curriculum, please?"
So Saif, that's actually a
subject close to my heart
as I described my career
before Khan Academy
was I was a financial analyst
and so
(chuckling)
we actually do have,
it's not mapped to the Indian curriculum,
but I will say if you want the intuition
of finance and accounting
Khan Academy does have
some resources for you already.
So feel free to look at that content.
I made a lot of that, actually,
when I was a financial analyst
and I saw that, you know,
even some of the junior
analysts we were hiring
who went to fancy colleges with 4.0 GPAs
when I asked them very
basic questions like,
"Okay, there's two identical houses.
"The rent on one house is x,
"the other house costs y to buy.
"Which one should I buy, rent or buy?"
And they'd say, "Oh I'd buy
y, I'd buy the second house".
And they're like,
"Okay now that price has
doubled on the second house
"while the rent is the
same on the first house.
"Now, which one?"
And they're like, "Oh, you're right."
And, so we try to give
those types of frameworks
of how you can think, how
very seemingly complex
situations in the economy or finance
could be broken down into a fairly simple
and intuitive framework.
So, definitely check
some of that content out.
And I hope in the future
we can do something
like a more formal finance,
accounting, capital markets
type course on Khan Academy.
We actually have a lot of
personal finance content.
It's a partnership with Bank of America
around better money habits.
We also have some career
content around that.
So check that content out as well.
So let's see.
There is a question.
YouTube ExplorerQuestioner.
Oh it's a testimonial, well that's nice.
You're saying, "You're amazing Sal".
You're being generous.
"Thank you for giving me the
opportunity to better myself
"and make myself useful, and
find more purpose in my life."
Well, ExplorerQuestioner on YouTube
that's why all of us here at Khan Academy,
and to be clear Khan Academy
is much more than me,
much more than me and Dan, (chuckling)
there's 200 plus other folks
who are doing a lot of work
and thousands of people,
but that's why we wanted
to dedicate our lives
to this mission.
Because, you know, at
the end if we can empower
millions of folks that's
going to have a multiplier,
or billions of folks,
that's going to have a
multiplier effect for the world.
You know, I sometimes
daydream that, you know,
the person who one day
can find the vaccine
for the next pandemic, or
solves an energy crisis,
or brokers peace between nations,
in a not too far off future says,
"Yes and I'm in this position
"because I was able to get my start,
"or with some help from Khan Academy."
So it really is motivating for us
to hear those types of things.
So from YouTube QualityMaterial asks:
"Firstly, Mr. Sal, how are you
dealing with the quarantine?
"Hope you're doing well."
So, QualityMaterial, Mr.
Material maybe I should call you,
(chuckling)
thanks for asking, I'm doing fine.
You know, obviously this is a
challenging time for everyone.
But I remind myself the whole
world is going through this
and relatively speaking I find myself
in a very fortunate situation.
You know, knock on wood I have
my health, my family does.
We have a backyard, we have a park nearby
that we can do to, staying
socially distanced appropriately.
My kids are, I'm really
enjoying time with my kids.
You know, it was hard at first,
trying to do work and at they're
screaming in the next room.
But we've kinda got a new normal now
and once again, it reminded me, like,
sometimes when you're doing work
and your child is screaming, or saying,
"Dada, dada, dada, let me show
you the thing that I made!"
You're kinda like,
"Oh, wait, wait, go away for a second
"I need to finish this
really important E-mail."
But there's something about this crisis
that makes you say,
"Well maybe this E-mail isn't as important
"as hanging out with my eight year old"
or, or whatever, so.
(chuckling)
I've actually enjoyed it
to kind of recenter
myself in a lot of ways.
I think my wife and I, you know,
were were just talking yesterday about
having all of various events,
or social things, or
things you have to go,
travel, all get canceled
and just us being home having quality time
it's kind of nice.
So I consider myself very fortunate.
Obviously I have a job where,
not only do I have a job now,
a lot of people who are
working in restaurants,
and other, you know, they're
losing their jobs now.
So for those of us who
are able to keep working
and keep having an income,
incredibly fortunate.
And I consider myself fortunate
that we have a role to play,
to help in the situation
on the education dimension
and getting information out dimension.
So, thanks for asking, but I
consider myself very lucky.
And I hope you are doing
well as well Mr. Material.
So, we are almost out, we
actually are out of time.
I'm maybe having too much fun,
but we're here every day
and we're gonna do more
of these just super
open-ended Ask Me Anythings.
I'm really enjoying the questions.
And all I'll say is thanks for joining.
I hope everyone has a
really really good weekend,
and I'll just remind folks
if you're in a position to do so
we are a not-for-profit,
we are running at a deficit,
and every donation matters.
So anything you could do to
help support Khan Academy
would mean a lot.
Thank you and stay safe and healthy.